happy Valentine's Day or what it's not
Valentine's Day yet perfect because I'm
gonna send you guys some Valentine's Day
treats 27 lucky people will be getting
Hannah Montana thousand times Day cards
one lucky winner will be getting this
amazing throw boy dot-com Valentine's
Day themed pillow this is seriously the
coolest thing I've ever seen in my
entire life
just in case you're a guy and you don't
want the paper and last I've got this
extremely large Valentine's Day card
that's I will so you're probably
wondering well how do we get these
amazing wonderful delicious delectable
treats it's easy I'm gonna be choosing
people from three separate locations if
you're watching this video you're
probably already subscribed to my views
on YouTube but if not go to youtube.com
slash iJustine and subscribe I'll be
choosing some people from there second
just retweet the text in the sidebar on
Twitter comm if you don't have an
account on Twitter feel free to sign up
and then you can follow me at twitter
comm slash iJustine last but not least
you can go to my website a Justine comm
and join my mailing list
I haven't yet decided which account is
gonna get which tree so if you do all
three things then my means do you have a
chance to get all three this fun treat
endeavor will end next Monday the 9th at
12 midnight Pacific I want to keep it
short so I can hopefully have a chance
to get you guys your treats by
Valentine's Day any other information
you need it's on my blog I just sing
calm and in the sidebar one of these
days I'll actually figure out which
direction that sidebar is in for now
Dover there
you